Dear Spike, Dear Oprah, Dear Stevie...
Your music has guided me through the most difficult moments of my life.
I get letters from so many people that share their stories.
I keep fighting voices in my mind...
...that say I'm not enough.
Whoa! Are all of these letters for me?
Remind me once again...
Every time you make something, you're throwing rocks in a pond.
You have no idea of the ripples that are going to come back to you...
...every time you make something.
All of us must stand up together.
If one person tells their story, that allows other people to say,...
"You know what, that happened to me, that's me there."
It's as though I'm watching my life and the lives of my students on screen.
I could speak to people about their problems because I grew up struggling.
You're fat, you're too brown.
Ballet was the first time I felt like, "Wow, I'm beautiful."
With you as an example, I've become the first black woman...
...to get a PhD in aerospace engineering.
I knew that I could defy the odds, too.
Oh my gosh.
That can transform everything.
You say I'm loved...
Big Bird, you showed me how to accept people for who they truly are, starting with myself.
Your music helped me create the Equal Justice Initiative.
That inspires me to want to write more songs and play them better.
You lit a fire inside of us, and we're lighting that same fire…
...in other kids around the world.
If every one of us focused on something that you want to change, we can change the world.
Your legacy is every life you've touched.